with us we have super grand master
former world blitz champion lenier
dominguez perez welcome to the show
linear
it has been a confusing round for us we
need you to help us out what is going on
today
yeah well i mean i was a bit surprised
with the game of uh rapport again
against nepo yeah because i think if you
go for this line with white i mean you
understand that it's uh this is a draw
and uh
um
it was a bit uh surprising to me that he
went for this position with 92 and did
you know it did you know it before the
game happened you are a public expert
i actually played this line once this
queen be free in a rapid game which
didn't go so well for me but i i was
aware that this is the best line for for
black or at least one of the best lines
and but it's of course if you don't know
that you have to play like this with
black
then it's it's very difficult but uh
clearly nepo knew the line well he
played all these moves uh very quickly
uh he knew bishop h3 of course
and then yeah i think it's of course
white has to repeat moves
but uh yeah to go for this position um
i i i didn't really understand uh why
richard went for this
because it looks i mean not only
uh
the computer gives of course a big
advantage to black but also if you look
from from the human point of view i mean
with such a king
it's uh it's clearly going to be very
easy for black to play and
um
i mean clearly white is is going to be
suffering here
linear uh first of all good to see you
my friend um is it as surprising for you
as it is for ourselves that we're seeing
a two horse race exclusively
everybody else is very very very slowly
drifting away
and it's all about the nepo and fabi
show
surprising for you that dingler in or
alireza farrugia a number of other
players haven't won a single game
yeah a bit i mean i was of course i was
thinking before the tournament that uh
fabiano and ding are the the favorites
i was actually thinking that dean might
do well because he's he's been very
consistent of the last few years and
um
he didn't have a great tournament the
last candidates but i thought that maybe
this is the one
where he is
going to play well
and he certainly has the level to to to
win the tournament
so and fabiano of course is very
experienced uh he's he's very very
strong so
i thought that uh those two players are
are going to be
the main uh the main favorites which is
not like a super revelation or something
uh but i think yeah from the rest i i i
kind of uh knew that nepo
i mean
from the rest i if i had to pick one to
let's say uh win the tournaments i
thought that nepal could be
maybe maybe one of them because first of
all already he he won once which shows
that he
he has
what it takes to to to win this
tournament and he's you know when he's
in shape and things are going well for
him he plays very quickly he he can beat
anyone easily and and and and he can win
tournaments so
uh not really surprising for me but i
think what we have seen in in the
candidates uh
traditionally is that uh the second uh
half of
uh brings uh some surprises uh normally
so players who are
let's say on the lower part of the table
uh start to win some games against
the people who are at the top and then
the tournament becomes more
interesting so let's hope that uh
there are still some excitement lanier
uh good to see you my friend first of
all uh what do you feel separates these
two players right now jan and fabiano
from the rest of the pack
uh well i think nepo clearly is is in
good shape
and as i was saying when he's in i feel
that when he's in good shape when things
are going
his way he can just be very very strong
as he was already as he showed already
in the last candidate
uh so
this seems to be one of his tournaments
so it's going to be hard to to
um to to fight with him
uh but i think yeah obviously fabiano
because also first of all he's uh
scoring pretty well in the tournament he
seems to be
playing well he's super well prepared
and very experienced so
um
so far i think those two obviously have
been the most consistent and
they seem to be
in shape so
uh the rest yeah they all seem to be a
bit uh
off uh of shape for example of erusia is
clearly not uh
not playing as at his uh best level
and uh and the same for for example dude
on rapport you see games like the one
today or i think richard was also losing
against uh brett javoff at some point
which shows that he's uh yeah probably
not in in his best shape
um
um yeah
it's about similar story i think with
the rest of the players it seems to be
the consistency that you mentioned of
these two players now as we enter the
second half of the event the big
question remains how is nepo going to
play in the second half of the event
what is your prediction
yeah i think he'll he'll continue to do
well i mean he might uh might lose some
game of course uh
it can happen to anyone there but uh but
uh
i i think that i mean if i had to
predict something i would say that he he
will do well so it it will be tough to
keep pace with him for faviano and other
players who might get close
so
um
let's see
okay before we let you go a couple of
things first of all give us your
insights on the current position of fabi
and timor and then you got to tell us
what's next on your schedule uh i i know
you're going to the olympiad right
fabi's just played the move queen d3 how
do you how do you like uh
the situation is extra pawn for white
yeah it doesn't look so easy of course
because um opposite color bishops and
black can
hope for some um some simplification and
and some drawing end game but
yeah clearly clearly white is
calling the shots here so it's winning
percentages do you see it as a two
result game
yeah i don't know it's i mean yeah it
seems seems to me that white should be
of course
um
the only the only player pushing here
but uh
but at the same time it doesn't i mean
it doesn't look so so easy to me
it feels like black can just be fine um
if if if white doesn't play
like uh super precise here super please
if i go
uh i don't know i can play knight b4
knight to d4
knight to b4 i apologize for your take
on d8 and um
i check first right
maybe queen g freya queen g3 check first
and like i'm guessing the king
king a8 get out of the way
get out of the way uh yeah well
the traitor
d8
yeah smack smack
a3 or something right to play knight d5
to play knight d5
uh good stuff and again back to you uh
lanier uh tell us what's uh
what's coming up for you
so i'm going to play the olympiad as you
mentioned but first uh i'm going to play
an online event
part of the
magnus tour
starting on july 10
and then um and then after that i'll
play the the granches tour in zagreb the
wrapping plates
and then i'll go from there to to india
to
to play the olympia so
three tournaments in a row now nice so
you've got a busy summer coming up now
lanier before we let you uh go now talk
to us about this decision of richie to
continue the game at that point in which
he got surprised in the opening he knew
that but he spent an hour and decided to
shy away from the repetition have you
ever been in in those type of situations
and what is usually your thought process
yeah i mean i don't know it
in fact i would be curious to see what
was his uh thinking because i i don't
think he was surprised i mean he played
all these moves quickly and when you
when you do that it's clear that you
looked at this position
and you know what's the what's the
objective evaluation so
uh i don't know if if he let's say just
didn't want to make it wrong
or if he thought that the position with
the with the two rooks for the queen
although he knew that the computer
estimates uh the position to be better
for black maybe he thought that
practically is
is is interesting for white maybe it's
not that easy
um that white uh can play it simply with
the two rooks
but uh but i don't think he was
surprised i mean i think he knew all
this because if you play this line with
white uh um you you're supposed to know
and i think he knew and he played all
those moves quickly
so yeah i don't know i i think he just
thought that the position it's it's any
way interesting for white that he might
be worse objectively but he maybe liked
his chances or something with with the
two rooks
but yeah again for me it's uh it's not
so
so easy to to understand why he
do you feel maybe it was a bit of a
frustration that he drew all his games
up to this point he's not used to
drawing so many games
any of that
it could be yeah it could could be but
uh but again if you let's say if you
feel the need to just
play and
and not make a draw then you might
choose a different line
because if you choose this it's clearly
very uh concrete line just move per move
uh either you
are better or it's it's
or or you have to to make it draw so uh
if you go for this line then i it seemed
to me that the the strategy was just to
test nabo if he if he plays the correct
uh line the correct moves
uh but yeah just to to go to go like
this it seems to me that uh the only uh
justification is that he he
he somehow
uh thought that the position is still
still interesting for white after after
this queen takes a freight and stuff
linear we just want to say thank you so
very much for taking time out of your
day
and joining us it was delight to have
you on the show and
get your insights very very good luck in
the future
thank you great to see you guys thank
you lanier great to have you on board
and of course he's going to be joining
the grand chester in zagreb